hey guys we're back at Roseanne's
kitchen table yes I'm talking about that
Roseann and what are we doing here well
there's an annotation right here that'll
explain a little bit more about what
we're doing here we're just basically
shooting the [ __ ] having a cup of coffee
although I heard the Jimmy door right
here is having tea
I was not alerted of that preemptively
but that's alright but we wanted to jump
in so the CIA report this torture report
was released this morning people of
course are freaking out about it we knew
about sleep deprivation we knew about
waterboarding the phrase rectal
rehydration is now in our lexicon and
then also standing on broken legs those
seem to be the big four and of course
everybody's very upset about this you
torture is one of your like sort of
wheelhouse things like you think this is
incredibly [ __ ] up am i right well I
think it's a well here's the thing we
don't call it torture right we call it
enhanced interrogation techniques which
sounds nice that's what we've been doing
for you that does it does sound like oh
it's enhanced so you're gonna put on
some mood music and a little track
lighting I'm not exactly we're gonna
hook your balls up to a car battery and
take turns drowning you yeah oh I'll
take the regular if the book don't make
a fuss over me yeah so the beauty is
they say it works torture works that's
what they've been telling me what else
works chemical weapons really works you
ever use a chemical weapon it kills
people like that dead don't you you
should do it that way they say as Jon
Stewart said that if because they go
well just in certain circumstances will
torture know if it's a human rights are
value if morality is a value you have to
do them when it's hard otherwise they're
just hobbies yeah so one of the things
we talk about all the time on my show on
The Young Turks everywhere is that it
actually doesn't work there seems to be
this theory that it works so they knew
it didn't work before it's already known
that's why you don't do this it doesn't
work and I love what they keep saying
today is oh my god you can't release
this because they're going to attack our
embassies but apparently continuous
bombing for 14 years doesn't piss them
off it's just releasing a report telling
people what we did as if they don't know
what the [ __ ] we did anyway right or as
if they're just sitting around waiting
for like yeah or things like it
Isis going you know I wasn't pissed off
before yeah now they're not they're
seriously pissed by the way we've bombed
seven different Muslim countries Arab
Muslim Muslim country since 9/11 seven
different ones is that all that's all I
don't I don't have my list in front of
me
but it's coming out now that the the
enhanced interrogation techniques not
only involved waterboarding which people
couldn't wrap their mind around how that
torture but things that people could
wrap their mind around that's why I
don't want it out right and I say this
if the people who are in favor of
torture say and they say it works
why would they want to keep it a secret
would they want to sprint tell everybody
it worked we're gonna let everybody know
what the good [ __ ] we did right so
speaking of the good [ __ ] we did one
thing that I keep thinking about with
this is you know remember we did a lot
about this together over the past year
the CIA director james clapper when he
got caught lying to Congress about the
NSA right so let me just get I just want
to try to understand I hear so if the
CIA director was lying to Congress and
also supposedly Congress didn't really
know what they were doing about torture
who's really in charge around here um
nobody's in charge or the guy who is in
charge is Barack Obama and he's not
going to do anything about it but didn't
he supposedly not really know about this
I mean even George Bush was saying what
two days ago that these people are
patriots he said no matter what happens
yeah whatever this report reveals these
people are patriots I'm sure and that's
what Hitler said about Mengele I mean
they're all Patriots right you just
patron in a different way you know at
least the good thing is the silver
lining is that Bush Cheney in the CIA
never jaywalked or sold loose cigarettes
it's the loose cigarettes that yeah
those are the crimes you have to enforce
to the full extent oh they didn't break
a window either so those are the crimes
that we're enforcing full set torture
war crimes illegal Wars and definitely
none of that [ __ ] doesn't matter yeah
anyway what do you guys make of this
whole the torture report it literally
came out like an hour ago so still
unfolding as we do this let us know in
the comments right down below